it's great to welcome to the program
today Alexandra Nadeau Poff who is
professor of law at the University of
California Irvine also author of the
book punishment without crime how our
massive misdemeanor system traps the
innocent and makes America more unequal
Alexandra so great to have you on I
appreciate it thanks so much for having
me
so maybe to begin with let's talk about
misdemeanor offenses there is sometimes
the not inaccurate understanding in the
public that being charged with a
misdemeanor is less serious than being
charged with a felony which is of course
true in terms of the potential jail and
prison time that can come with it but
what you argue in the book is that there
is a whole system around and surrounding
misdemeanor offenses that has this
disproportionate impact on people who
are charged let's start there how does
it all work and how should we understand
the idea of misdemeanor offenses so
you're absolutely right they
misdemeanors are by definition less
serious than felonies that's how we
define misdemeanor and felony in our
criminal system it's worth remembering
that our felony system is
internationally infamous for being harsh
and punitive we lock up more people in
this country than any other nation on
the planet both in terms of absolute
numbers and percentages so our mass
incarceration has increased and and and
harsh and the way we handle felonies and
I think that's in many ways overshadowed
the profound harshness of our
misdemeanor system our misdemeanor
system is enormous it comprises eighty
percent of American criminal dockets
this is mostly what our criminal system
does and a misdemeanor technically
legally speaking is an offense for which
a person can serve no more than one year
incarceration even that definition is a
little broad there are two three four
year misdemeanors but the basic idea is
that there is an enormous world of
low-level offenses for which people are
and
punished less harshly than felonies but
there are millions of them and we are
punishing people often quite harshly for
their entire lives based on low-level
conduct based on minor crimes minor
behavior disorder crimes low-level theft
crimes sometimes things we don't even
think of his crimes loitering and
spitting spitting and jaywalking and
this is the bulk of what our criminal
system does to millions of people every
year so let's talk a little bit about
felony versus misdemeanor and then
misdemeanor versus nothing right so we
often read about particular cases where
someone is accused of having committed a
crime we read they could have been
charged with a felony but instead either
through an agreement or prosecutorial
discretion they were charged with a
misdemeanor instead you're still talking
about a case you're still talking about
a sort of court proceeding that's going
to have to be adjudicated in one way or
another when we talk about misdemeanor
or nothing at all we are now having a
sort of much more binary discussion
about is someone going to now be in the
system potentially requiring legal
assistance potentially on probation for
years at a time what will the impact the
unemployment so the difference between
misdemeanor or nothing seems to be one
we're selective application of the law
or discriminatory enforcement has this
all-or-nothing sort of impact in a sense
I think that's right the way to think
most I mean misdemeanors in your terms
to all or nothing quality of it is that
we've created an enormous net that
sweeps people up not for that original
felony that might get pled down to a
misdemeanor but for a very low level
conduct in the first place for loitering
for trespassing for spitting for
jaywalking for low-level thefts there
are aspects of course of our misdemeanor
system that do reach out and touch more
serious conduct
think of domestic violence is the
paradigmatic serious misdemeanor DUI of
course is a serious offense but from
many many millions of these cases people
are being brought into the criminal
system initially not because they are
particularly dangerous or harmful or bad
or scary as in the way they are brought
in for more serious felony offenses but
because they have committed level
conduct that we have gotten into the
habit of treating as a crime and it is
that decision the decision to
criminalize so much low-level conduct to
expand our criminal system in this
profoundly sweeping way that that the
book asks us to reconsider what can you
tell us in terms of the data around what
we would call I guess these less serious
misdemeanors and you can tell us what
you sort of include in that whether as
you mentioned its loitering jaywalking
etc what do we know about the unfair way
that that may be applied to either poor
people non-white people whatever sort of
discriminatory application you've
identified how can we quantify that yeah
that's a great question because we
actually have so little data about the
misdemeanor system it's many of these
courts many of these dockets operate a
little bit under the radar we don't keep
very good track of them for the book I
did new research around the country to
come to the estimate the best estimate
that we now have that there are
approximately 13 million misdemeanor
cases filed every year in this country
when I collected that data I asked every
state for their misdemeanor dockets and
for who is in those misdemeanor doctors
who are being who's being swept up how
are those offenses being enforced what
offenses make up those dockets and most
states didn't give me that information
some states told me that they that their
data systems were too outdated to
collect it or that they weren't willing
to make that data public I
we have spotty data around the country
that indicates in much the same way as
we now know about mass incarceration
that many of these low-level offenses
are disproportionately enforced against
the poor and against people of color and
we know that because of the nature of
the policing so one of the things that I
discuss in the book and a chapter
entitled money is how our misdemeanor
system as we say as we put it
criminalizes poverty it goes after poor
people almost by definition so many
misdemeanors are crimes of poverty it is
a many people drive for example on a
suspended license their license is
suspended because they couldn't pay a
ticket a fine or a fee wealthy people
well resource people will never be
charged with that kind of offence
homeless people of course are a famous
example they they're their crimes are
crimes of poverty sleeping and living
and existing on the street and so the we
use the low level system the low level
criminal system and many ways to sweep
up people based on their inability to
pay and then of course as has become
infamous after Ferguson sometimes we
lock them up after they've been charged
with a crime when they can't pay the
fines and fees that we have imposed upon
them for the for the original offense
and by that same token low-level
policing and low-level misdemeanor
conduct often sweeps up people of color
in part because we heavily police those
communities more heavily for these
low-level con low-level offenses so
people in those neighborhoods are more
likely to encounter the misdemeanor
system and then we see in jurisdictions
all over the country that offenses order
offenses like disorderly conduct and
loitering and jaywalking are
disproportionately enforced against
people of color and so that net if you
will that misdemeanor net is in many
ways the first step in creating the
racial disparities we see throughout our
criminal system so let's talk a little
bit about the jail time
opponent it wouldn't be unreasonable as
someone observing this system to think
that the top priority for anyone charged
with a misdemeanor would be to avoid
jail time just period right at whatever
option is available to avoid jail time
that's what you do you write in the book
that this is often not the case can you
talk a little bit about what the
circumstances are that lead to that and
why someone might accept jail time in
certain situations where they are
charged with misdemeanors yes so it
turns out that the punishment calculus
the calculations that individual people
make about about their choices in
cutting a plea deal and accepting a plea
deal are very complicated so for some
people avoiding jail time as you point
out is all-important they have children
they have a job they're afraid that if
they remain incarcerated they will lose
things that are vital importance to them
and so one of the things we see is that
many people will plead guilty rather
than contest their cases particularly if
they can't afford bail even when they
may be innocent or mean even when they
may have meritorious legal issues that
they could pursue they'd they'd rather
get out of jail as quickly as possible
and so they will accept wrongful
convictions or unfair punishment as the
price as the price of their freedom and
conversely and this was one of the
lessons I learned when I was a federal
and assistant federal public defender in
Baltimore many years ago for some people
the the long-term engagement with the
criminal system supervision and
probation the the now onerous fines and
fees that many people that are imposed
on many people when they are being
supervised supervision fees drug testing
fees tether fees electronic monitoring
fees over the months over the years of
supervision can
to an enormous burden being on probation
is deeply intrusive your house can be
searched you have to check in with your
probation officer you can't change jobs
you often can't leave your your
jurisdiction and so for many people they
would rather suffer through the the
burden and the weight of being
incarcerated for a briefer period of
time rather than turning their lives and
their in their liberty and their privacy
over to the state for a long period of
time so we've been talking about a lot
of the problems with the way the system
exists currently of course you pointed
out that there are misdemeanors that are
serious you talked about drunk driving
you talked about domestic violence and
many others
so what reforms do you believe should be
made to the system such that there is
not this idea that people who are
actually committing crimes that should
not be ignored
will still potentially face consequences
but we can fix a lot of the problems
that you identify yeah I think that's
the right way to think about it we have
this enormous system that's incredibly
important we need a functional
misdemeanor system that can respond
properly and fairly illegally to low
level harms and we have we have
overwhelmed that we fill it with chump
change
cases cases that might not have been
brought in the first place
if for example courts and probation
offices and prosecutorial offices and
sheriff's departments were not reliant
on the revenue source from those
low-level offenses in fact we have
created dysfunctional incentives making
it rational for many criminal justice
institutions to want to expand the
misdemeanor system to include many
low-level offenses to the detriment of
the integrity of the entire system and
as you say in the book I I make a number
of suggestions about the kinds of
reforms we can engage in they are not
pie-in-the-sky reforms they are being
engaged in it
many jurisdictions around the country
actually in in in cities and towns and
states in a kind of retail retail way
these but the take away the heart of the
matter is that we can shrink the system
that we do not need to be indeed we
should not be using our low level
criminal system this is vitally
important public institution on which we
all rely to raise money to be a revenue
source for criminal justice institutions
we shouldn't use it to criminalize
poverty we have better tools at our
disposal through the welfare system to
handle people who are suffering from
homelessness who have mental health
issues who have substance abuse problems
I to maintain the to enforce
gentrification boundaries well many
times we use low-level order maintenance
policing to clear coroner's or to
control the appearance of neighborhoods
not because these offenses are are
harmful not because these people are
criminals but because because
neighborhoods are gentrifying or
downtown's are gentrifying and these are
ways of enforcing those economic
boundaries the argument is that the
low-level criminal system is a crude and
poor and harsh tool for accomplishing
many of these public policy work on many
of them worthy public policy goals but
we have gone overboard in using this
particular tool and we should roll it
back yeah sort of the use of an axe when
maybe a scalpel is more appropriate to
use a kind of tired tired metaphor the
book is called yeah the the book is
called punishment without crime how our
massive misdemeanor system traps the
innocent and makes America more unequal
we've been speaking with the book's
author Alexander nano puff professor of
law at UC Irvine thank you so much for
talking to me today
thanks so much for having